well Hunter Biden is playing the victim
in a brand new interview as we learn
bombshell new details about his second
indictment the first son is facing nine
new criminal charges for allegedly not
paying more than not paying for more
than 1 point4 million in taxes well at
the same time blowing that cash on his
lavish lifestyle from the indictment
quote the defendant spent his money on
drugs escorts and girlfriends luxury
hotels and rental properties exotic cars
clothing and other items of personal
nature in short everything but his taxes
if convicted Hunter could be spending
the next 17 years of his life in prison
but never mind his corruption Hunter
Biden telling musician Mobi in a new
interview that Republicans are only
concerned about him as a way to destroy
his father's
presidency in their most uh illegitimate
way but rational way they're trying to
destroy a presidency and so it's not
about me in their most base way what
they're trying to do is they're trying
to kill me knowing that it will be a
pain greater than my father could be
able to handle Hunter's attorney is also
blaming Republicans he thinks the
political pressure from GOP lawmakers
played a role in beefing up the charges
after the first son's sweetheart plea
deal fell apart what happened between
June 20th and yesterday the facts didn't
change what changed was the enormous
political pressure that was put on the
US attorney when he made a deal that was
appropriate for what the facts and law
showed to him deciding I don't want that
brief any longer I don't want to be
ridiculed by the Republican party of
which I'm a member so I'll just show be
a tough guy and now I'm going to take
two pages of a misdemeanor where
millions of Americans file Aid and turn
it into a 56 page document is if his
name wasn't Hunter Biden this would not
have happened so how's Joe Biden feeling
about this second indictment of his son
well it seems like he's too busy
thinking about which celebrities he'll
be hanging out with tonight at a
fundraiser in California watch him
completely ignore reporters asking about
Hunter any comment on the new charges
against your son Mr
President well judge I think you
disagreed with Hunter's attorney Abby
LEL I got to tell you if I were ever in
trouble I would hire Abby LEL but he's
he's wrong here look the the the truth
of the matter is that he had a plea deal
that even the Department of Justice
could not justify even the Department of
Justice one question by judge naraka
said there's no precedent for anything
like this so you know Abby with all due
respect don't tell me that you know this
is uh that that nothing uh uh has
changed here what has changed is is the
fact that Joe that Hunter Biden is being
held responsible and accountable this is
not a guy who filed late returns this is
a file who didn't file a guy who didn't
file returns and you know what for
everybody including the Associated Press
who says well you know he was an
addicted son I'm here to tell you that
his tax failures were post addiction
issues so stop with this he was a
druggie I mean first of all how smart I
mean I couldn't take out $1.6 billion
from a uh from the city bank account
where I do my banking I mean and he was
involved in human trafficking money
laundering he was a foreign agent none
of that stuff was filed here this is
nothing more than lipstick on a peg all
they did was take the same charges and
then tell us everything we already know
knew about this dirt bag's lifestyle and
I'm referring to Hunter when I call him
a dirt bag and let me say this no one's
trying to kill you people are just
trying to make sure that there is the
same Justice for you as there is for
everybody body else in America and let
me just say one final thing and that is
that for those who say oh Joe Biden has
nothing to do with this you've got James
comr and and Congress trying to do what
the Department of Justice and the FBI
should be doing 327 emails with Joe
Biden using a pseudonym instead of his
real name contacting members who are
partners of Hunter Biden lying he didn't
know about his son's businesses lying
that he never did business with China
didn't do anything illegal with China
didn't take money from China and lying
when he said he didn't do anything
illegal period you know what Jame Biden
got money we still don't know where $20
million has gone into those shell
accounts James Biden sent money to Joe
Biden and we still haven't seen a uh a
memo that indicates it was
alone you know Harold uh Hunter's
attorneys are trying to make the case
that nothing has changed here but we did
see a change in the sense that these IRS
whistleblowers came forward to to talk
about what they were and were not
allowed to pursue so I think it's
important to listen to them again now to
remind them of what they were
saying it appeared to me based on what I
experienced that the US attorney in
Delaware in our investigation was
constantly hamstrung limited and
marginalized by doj officials as well as
other us attorneys a number of times we
were not able to follow the facts
prosecutors instructed investigators not
to ask about the big guy or dad when
conducting interviews investigators were
not allowed to follow up on WhatsApp
messages from Hunter Biden's Apple
iCloud backup where he suggested he was
sitting next to his father and Harold
these were not Republican they were you
Republicans they were career IRS
investigators who were making these it
do matter first of all good to see
everybody it doesn't matter me what any
political party anybody's in when you
when you're accused of something the
greatest thing we have in our nation our
judicial system and our legal system
affords is a presumption of innocence uh
every American gets that uh it is
curious uh president Trump uh has said
over and over again with what he's
facing that he would not be facing some
of the charges he's facing if he were
not his name was not Trump and Mr Mr
said that uh I think Hunter Biden even
said that he would not be facing these
chares so they if he were not named
Biden so both of them are using a
similar kind of political argument two I
I have not read the indictment closely
enough although um I've read summaries
of it and this is a serious indictment
yeah uh and there's there's jail time
that goes along with this uh Hunter has
said that he's innocent he's and we give
him that presumption we'll have to wait
for the facts to come out for a trial to
be held I do think with regard to the
the the witnesses that you showed Katie
at the start of at the start of your
asking me the question um this all blew
up remember because they went into a
courtroom in Delaware and the two sides
did not have a meaning of the minds
about what the plea agreement was about
hunter's team thought it would cover
everything that it was a global blanket
immunity agreement and the justice
department thought it pertained only to
the matters that I think the gun stuff
and some tax stuff in a couple number of
years the justice department knew
because they hit it in the plea deal
regarding the gun and the judge was
upset yeah let's just get back to the
facts I understand people around here
want to see him bury it and want to see
maybe want to see his father no I just
want to see justice so do I so in that
courtroom the greatest thing that
happened in a courtroom judge that is
that that that hearing was held to
defend the defendant to let the
defendant know when you plead guilty to
something you get to go before a judge
and the judge explains you understand
what you're pleading to and guess what
neither side understood you may say the
justice department knew I don't know
what they wrote it up how could they not
understand it the justice department
wrote it up so what happened was the
outcome is what you want in your
Judicial System the court said you all
are not in agreement so this thing is
off theable this is corrupt it's never
been done before right well whatever the
case the court said this is not you all
do not have an agreement so Katie even
when those whistle blor what I was
trying to get at judge the whistle blers
did what they did they didn't do this it
was that judge that put us where we are
because she said you guys do not have an
agreement now now I think if I were in
Hunter shoes today I would be
disappointed that I didn't sign that
agreement because you at least taken
some of those charges off the table so
where we are today the only point I'm
making guys if if if when we get the
facts and he goes before a jury and if
he's convicted guess what he'll have to
face the proverbial legal music and if
that is not the case if he's acquitted
then it's a new indictment 58 Pages lots
of salacious details Pete and the number
one thing is about the taxes on money
but how did he get that money and who
were his partners and media is going out
of their way to try and distance Joe
Biden from the indictment
listen no mention of Joe Biden no
reference to Joe Biden in the indictment
Hunter Biden is not President Joe Biden
and there is no allegation in the
56-page indictment that the president
did anything wrong Hunter Biden he was
never worked in the white house he's not
running for office um and this is a
false equivalency being set up by
Republicans I don't see any Link in the
indictment or even in Comer's statement
to Joe Biden so we'll see we'll see if
James comr has
Point yeah and there's yet to be any
evidence that that President Biden had
anything to do with the criminal charges
his son now faces so we move from never
being in business never knowing about
business to not being in the indictment
yeah I mean this is what the media does
they're going to cover for him
ultimately it's so telling of the moment
we're told that this is Justice Harold
you said it's a serious indictment and
and and on its face it is but it's the
exact opposite of Justice why drop it
now well he's about to testify before
James Co where he's going to have to
answer questions now he's under
investigation can't talk about that
anymore no more will he really see
Justice everyone saying 17 years you
hear other people out there saying it's
there's no way it's going to be 17 years
and even if he was found guilty what's
Joe going to do before he leaves office
he's going to wave his magic pardon wand
okay this is this is the opposite of
Justice they don't mention his lobbying
maybe one sentence about lobbying they
don't mention anything about suspicious
activity reports about sudum and emails
about International money I think
there's one sentence in there about
money from Russia and China they know
exactly what's there and they found the
easiest thing to say okay he didn't pay
his taxes and he paid hookers instead
okay let's throw the mini little book at
them call it justice and call it even so
we can compare it to Trump which is an
entirely different circumstance so Jimmy
do you want to Enlighten us about the
jokes you have decided to pull stop it I
had a point here I had a I had a serious
Point first of all reacting to what
Hunter said to Mobi okay they're not
trying to destroy Biden's presidency
Biden doesn't need help destroying his
presidency the guy is polling behind
Isis right now okay like
27% okay but to the hunter point I give
him a D in accounting but I do give him
an A on how he spent the money I'm not
going to lie fast cars fast women okay
if Ukraine sending me 5 million I got to
be honest with you the docket looks very
similar to the way it looks now but the
point is they wouldn't send me the money
because my dad wasn't the sitting Vice
President of the United States at the
time and what did we keep coming back to
as an alibi is this well Hunter didn't
work in the government exactly so why
was Biden emailing him government
information under a pseudonym while that
money was flowing into the Biden bank
accounts and by Biden bank accounts I'm
talking dozens of shell companies that
ultimately wound up with a grandkid like
every family who has nothing to hide and
that's the bigger takeaway here they
interfered in the 2020 election and we
all know they did why because we were
told this isn't even a thing you can't
talk about this not a thing it'll
wrongly influence the election now we're
sitting here with guilty pleas to the
very money we knew was a thing
scam scam all right up next the Cowardly
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else